many people focus on the the  establishment of the international  criminal court and the building of that  institution as an important element of  the international criminal justice  system i actually think what will be  more important going forward is the way  in which  national systems are building  international criminal justice into  their own penal codes so around the  globe states are incorporating  international crimes into their codes  they're initiating prosecutions both  arising out of their own histories and  also with respect to others who are  within their jurisdiction i think the  role that domestic courts play in  enforcing international criminal law is  going to be increasingly important and  that's where the real  excitement is going to be happening in  the next couple of years in this field